Support for Think Fast, Talk Smart
comes from Stanford Continuing Studies.
Stanford Continuing Studies offers
over 150 online classes on a wide
range of topics from art history to AI,
wellness to writing,
as well as courses on business and
communication.
Fall registration opens August 16th and
is open to all adult learners everywhere.
Most classes start the week
of September 20th.
Learn more at
continuingstudies.stanford.edu.
[MUSIC]
This podcast is dedicated to
helping people deal with everyday
business challenges with confidence and
conviction.
However, today we're going
to take a different tack.
We're going to look at another
challenge that many of us face,
helping teenagers become adults.
And the things that we learn in this
conversation will actually help us be
better in the workplace.
I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast,
Talk Smart, the podcast.
I am really looking forward to
speaking with Julie Lythcott-Haims.
Julie is multi-talented,
a lawyer by training, and
a former dean of freshmen and
undergraduate advising at Stanford.
She is now a much sought after speaker and
the author of the award winning book,
How to Raise an Adult,
Break Free of the Overparenting Trap and
Prepare Your Kid for Success.
Julie now has a new book,
Your Turn, How to be an Adult.
Thanks for being here, Julie.
>> Matt, thanks so much for having me.
I'm really looking forward to
communicating with you today.
>> [LAUGH] Excellent, me too.
Let's jump right in.
Can you define what you
mean by the term adulting?
And can you share some of
the challenges parents and
kids face during
the transition to adulthood?
>> Sure thing, well,
I guess I need to start by giving
a nod to the millennial generation.
They're the ones who
coined the verb adulting.
I don't want to adult.
I don't know how to adult.
Adulting is scary.
And their anguish,
their angst over not knowing how or
wanting to is really what
led me to write this thing.
Then I had to examine what adulting meant,
and I came up with this as the definition.
Adulting is simply the phase of
life between childhood and death,
where you're not dependent upon
other people to plan, chart,
fix, manage,
handle the stuff of life for you.
Where you have this delicious freedom and
independence.
And the terrifying knowledge that, hey,
it's kind of on me to figure this out,
which is not to say any of
us ever has to go it alone.
So that's what adulting is.
And the challenges when it comes to
parents and kids is, as parents,
we grew this child in our body perhaps,
or adopted into our family,
or our partner gave birth to it.
And we are completely responsible
in those early months and years.
But over the course of that child's life,
we're supposed to be slowly moving
from being completely in charge of their
life to turning the reins over to them.
And I think this big leap
from the end of high school,
the start of college, the start of work,
the start of military life,
whatever awaits after high school is
to leap over a chasm in some ways.
I mean, there's a sense that, my gosh,
there's a big gap I might fall into or
I might not make it.
And, of course, that's not literally true.
But I think it's an important moment for
us as parents to be preparing for,
to be thinking, okay, what do I want
to have confidence my kid can do when
they're no longer living in our home?
When I'm no longer the primary one
responsible for their food, and
their shelter, and
their day-to-day well-being?
We want to be parenting
in the teenage years, and
even earlier toward the inevitability
that we all want this young person
to be a free-standing adult who
can fend for themselves one day.
>> And it is so fraught with challenges.
I am going through this
now as a parent myself.
It sounds like it's really balancing
between freedom and responsibility,
both for parents, as well as for kids.
What advice and guidance do you have for
helping parents and
kids communicate about some of these
challenges in achieving this balance?
>> You're absolutely right that
it's freedom and responsibility.
I can hear John Hennessey, who was
president when I last worked at Stanford,
every year giving the graduation speech.
And really helping the graduates
understand that with this freedom and
independence comes responsibility.
Responsibility isn't a bad thing.
Responsibility is actually
an amazing thing.
And I think we parents have to do
a better job of narrating to that truth.
That is, you're going to be responsible
for more of your own things.
You're going to be responsible for making
sure your homework is in its bag and
taken to school.
You're going to be responsible for
making your own lunch.
making your own doctor's appointments.
Conveying the expectation that these
things will be turned over to the kid, and
that that's not a bad thing.
You're actually trusting that
they either can already or
can almost handle that task.
It's really by handing somebody
some additional responsibility,
which we're supposed to be doing
increasingly over the years of childhood.
We're actually signaling,
I believe you can.
And that turns out, Matt, to be a really
important indicator of a person's
wellness, the extent to which they believe
they can do the task in front of them.
So a vote of confidence
from a parent saying, hey,
you're going to be responsible for
this now.
As long as it's done kindly as opposed to
feeling like your parent has turned your
back on you, it's really quite empowering
to be given additional responsibility.
And that's how the freedom and
the responsibility really
nicely then go together.
>> So it sounds to me like part
of the challenge is to set clear
expectations along the way, but
also to think about the tone
in which you're communicating
those messages.
So that as you're having these
conversations, you're being supportive,
but also very clear about
what is happening now and
will happen in the future, is that right?
>> Exactly right, I mean, I think we're
at our best when we're parenting,
when we're providing unconditional love,
a tremendous amount of empathy,
optimism that the kid is going
to be able to make their way.
So the tone of voice, the body language
needs to be that of a compassionate,
yet emotionally somewhat distant adult.
And this may sound a bit odd to people.
Aren't we parents supposed to
be very close to our kids?
And kind of why would you advocate for
psychological distance?
What I'm responding to is
the overparenting tendency, which says,
your homework needs to get done.
You need to get an A.
You need to get into this college or
go off and do this career so
that I feel okay as a parent.
That's the psychological intertwinedness
that's actually really unhealthy for
both the kid and for the parent.
The more healthy distance is when you
can care very much about how they are,
you can offer help and guidance.
But you're not feeling that you own
every single thing that they do,
whether it's their homework, or their
activities, or their college applications.
We want to be in this place where our
child has the agency, the autonomy,
to kind of make their own way and
have their experiences.
Make their choices, fall a little bit
here and there, pick themselves up and
be stronger based on
what they experienced.
And our tone needs to be even and
positive, optimistic, kind and
loving, but never nudging them like,
why aren't you doing it better?
We expect better of you, and
certainly not being disinterested.
It's sort of like, picture how loving,
you can be with your niece or nephew, or
your best friend's kid.
Where you care about the kid, but
you don't feel obligated to tell them
precisely what to do all the time,
and you don't feel obligated
to solve their problem.
That's the healthy psychological
distance I think we are going for
actually as parents.
>> I really like that image,
that will be very helpful to me, and
hopefully many other folks.
And I like how you highlighted it.
It's not just about what you say but
how you say it,
that non-verbal openness
is really critical.
We have on this podcast talked about
improvisation in lots of different ways to
help people be present oriented,
to help people feel more
comfortable speaking spontaneously.
You talk about adopting principles
from improv and design thinking,
to help when people feel stuck.
Can you tell us more about this and
how this can help?
>> Yeah, so a lot of people who
are trying to spread their wings and
enter adult land feel stuck.
And I think part of
that is the sense that,
I have to know what I'm doing in advance.
I have to be really good at it before I
even start, kind of a perfectionistic
tendency, I have to know what I want,
I have to know who I am.
And I think an overarching message
of this new book, Your Turn is, hey,
you don't have to know,
you don't have to have it all figured out.
The point is, just start to move
in the direction of something.
And so both from the D school folks and
from improv more broadly,
I borrowed the language bias
toward action is anywhere.
And I think in whether you're a designer
or whether you're an improv actor
trying to entertain an audience,
it's just all about let's go.
Let's just try something, let's,
this isn't about it has to be perfect.
This is just about what can happen when
we leave this point we're stuck in,
or standing in our comfort zone perhaps,
or our stuck zone perhaps.
And just take a step in any direction,
you will learn something,
you will have an experience.
You will analyze the data, how you felt,
what you might do differently,
and all of that begins to
create some velocity forward.
>> The bias towards
action is such a powerful
lesson from both design thinking and
improv, and
and it plays out in lots of ways in our
relationships and in our communication.
There's a corollary to that notion which
is good is great, good enough is great,
and it's this notion that we put
a lot of pressure on ourselves.
And one of the reasons we don't move
forward, is we're afraid it won't go
the way we want or
it won't be as good as it could be.
And just giving ourselves permission to
move forward is really, really powerful.
In your book, Your Turn,
you have a chapter entitled
start talking to strangers.
Can you explain the advice you give in
this chapter, and share any breath best
practices you have that can help people
use communication to connect with others?
>> Yeah, I think that chapter opens by
saying this, or in the first couple of
paragraphs, this may be the most
obvious point I make in the book, but
every single human is a stranger
to you at the outset.
I'm deliberately subverting the childhood
norm, don't talk to strangers.
>> Yeah.
>> Young adults were raised with, and
making the point that this
was an overbroad rule.
The rule should have been learned, let me
teach you how to discern the one creepy
stranger from the vast majority of
humans who are perfectly fine child.
Let me let you walk
through the world with me,
watching how I discern whether
a stranger is okay to talk to.
Instead, we've given this overbroad rule
don't talk to strangers, and many, many,
many, many young people
really don't know how to be.
They feel afraid, they feel unsure,
they feel something's wrong if
stranger is trying to talk to them.
And that's boy, if there's anything
that's inhibited, or really prevented
a normal free flowing conversation
between people who've not previously met.
This mantra,
don't talk to strangers, maybe it.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, we shouldn't,
blanket rules rarely apply, right?
In the instinct about how
to approach somebody.
You're going to have to talk to strangers
when you leave your family home,
you're going to go to a college or
a community college, or
the workplace with the military.
There would be people who have
information that you need.
There will be people who
can help you on your path.
There will be people that you can help.
And, all of those things are going to
require us opening our mouths and
talking to this person.
But that's not all, I mean we've got to
be respectful toward this other person.
We've got to also have a sense of
how to advocate for ourselves.
Communication is such a delicate dance,
and
kids need to emerge from
childhood having practiced that.
Here's a fascinating thing that I end
up putting in the pages of Your Turn,
that I got from psychologists and
Stanford alum Laurie Gottlieb.
Because Julie so
many young adults don't know how to
communicate with their significant others,
or their boyfriend their girlfriend,
the person they're dating.
And they show up in her therapy practice,
and they say I broke up with my boyfriend
we had an argument, and he wasn't 100%
there for me, so I just I dropped him.
And she says Julie,
here's what I think is going on.
Their childhood communication,
conversations were so regulated by well
meaning parents, teachers, other adults
who sorted out difficulties when
kids weren't getting along on
the playground, or on a play date.
Who gave the kids language to use, to talk
to the other kids, not trusting the kids
could ever figure this out themselves
without a little bit of guidance, right?
A lot of adults did that handling.
Now, we've got a set of young adults,
who haven't had that practice on
the playground, in play dates,
in group play with their peers.
And they think that when
someone loves them,
it means I'll drop
everything to support you.
Parents basically behave that way.
>> Right.
>> You're not having school,
I'll go argue with the teacher for you.
And, instead of letting the student
practice, the child practice,
how to have a difficult conversation with
somebody, so they become this young adult.
Who doesn't have the skills to
communicate in what we would call
run of the mill situations.
A conversation with a friend,
a conversation with a lover,
a conversation with a colleague or a boss.
We've got to let our kids, we need to
want for our kids to practice, practice,
practice communicating with their fellow
humans well before they ever leave our
homes, if they're to make
it in the world one day.
>> The notion of practice and giving space
to learn how to communicate better is so
important, and then helping them.
I can imagine you would agree with this,
to reflect on that communication.
So you can learn from it and
do it differently or better,
is also a valuable skill to add there.
>> Absolutely.
>> So I'm going to ask you to get a little
meta here, Julie, if that's okay.
I have seen you speak on
a number of occasions, and
you are a phenomenal speaker.
And an actually,
a great meeting facilitator as well, and
and those two don't always go together.
Can you share some of the things
you think about and do,
to prepare yourself and your content
before you present or facilitate?
>> Yeah, it feels a little personal,
but I'm not criticizing or critiquing,
I'm just acknowledging.
That I am going to tell you
that the honest truth, and
honest to God truth here,
>> Please.
>> I am spiritual but not religious.
And, as a way to kind of get
my mindfulness game going,
when I'm backstage about
to give a big talk,
I offer what some might call a prayer.
I am trying to summon my gratitude for
where I am and for what's about to happen.
And for something that's,
whatever's going on in my life,
I then ask,
please let me have access to my intellect,
to my sense of humor, to my intuition.
Let me connect.
Let me help everybody here somehow feel
seen in the message I'm trying to deliver.
I'm centering myself.
I'm trying to create space
between wherever I just was,
hurrying to get there if
I'm late pre pandemic.
The traffic was bad or
I left too late or, I'm a little stressed,
I just try to put a buffer between
everything that came up to that happened
before that moment and
the moment that I'm entering.
I'm trying to create a new container
which the conversation whether it's
a speech to an audience or a conversation
among humans where I am just one of,
I'm a fraction of the of the whole.
I'm trying to be intentional about
what I need to do to create a safe and
welcoming and interesting and
engaging conversational experience.
>> Thank you first for
sharing that and second, so
many things going on in that ritual
that you go through that are so helpful.
The ability to be present, and
getting yourself in the present moment.
Focusing through what you called prayer,
others called mantra,
just focusing on the strengths
that you bring to the situation.
Many of us feel so intimidated and think
about all the deficiencies we have before
we communicate in front of others and
to focus on our strengths can only help.
And to really think about the experience
I love that idea of the container that's
being created and thinking about
that experience can only help.
So many lessons to learn in
what you just shared and in so
many lessons to learn in watching
you speak and facilitate.
Before we end, I'd like to ask
you the same three questions,
I asked everyone who
joins me on this podcast.
Are you up for that?
>> I'm up for it, Matt.
>> Excellent, number one,
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would that be?
Stop using slides.
>> [LAUGH] That might be the best
answer to that question given
that I'm asking for a slide title.
Excellent, tell me more.
Tell me what slides,
what is it about slides that bother you?
>> Yeah, well, I think some people
do manage to use slides quite
artfully as a way to enhance whatever it
is they're doing with their body language.
>> Right.
>> And the actual language but too many of
us, no matter how many degrees you have or
what role you play of
importance in the world,
really rely on the slide
to tell the story.
To tell the experience people end up
glazing over they read your slide instead
of reading you.
>> Yes.
>> Look, my work is about connecting
with humans, humans to humans.
I actually am interested in
the energy that we can create.
That exists in our bodies
that we can strengthen and
raise, and share, and receive from others.
So my work when I'm, this is what makes
the pandemic so hard for a speaker like
me, I'm trying to create energy through
a Zoom experience and a webcam.
But I'm really interested in like,
what can you feel radiating from
the message that I am delivering and the
slide I think if I was to use slides and
you can probably tell from
my answer that I don't.
I would just use imagery, some kind of
image to enhance rather than words.
I think it's too confusing.
>> Allow me to go to question number two,
who is a communicator that you admire and
why?
>> Oprah Winfrey has had a resurgence not
say Oprah wasn't ever always on our minds.
But she did this amazing interview
recently with Harry and Megan.
>> Yes.
>> So we all billions of
people got to see her again.
But I began watching Oprah I think she
her afternoon Chicago based talk show was
on when I was either in late, my late high
school years certainly my college years.
She conveyed such a mad respect for
humans,
a deep curiosity about the why behind
people's actions and language.
And ultimately you could be having
a really tough conversation with somebody
because the topic was tough or
because what they did was difficult bad,
wrong, etc.
Or concerning but she managed to elucidate
difficult subjects without judgment and
I thought it was the most profound
intersection of curiosity,
respect, and truth.
I mean, Oprah was always
going to tell her own truth.
But you would feel even if she was
disagreeing with you, you would feel
held in her arms as she did it, and
I just thought that was magnificent.
>> I like the way you
dissected that curiosity,
respect, and truth and
certainly she is an expert at all of that.
What are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> Maya Angelou, I believe said, they're
not going to remember what you said.
They're going to remember how
they felt when you said it.
Matt, for 10 years I had the distinct,
humbling joy of being the dean
of freshmen on the Stanford campus and
I got a big speech,
many big speeches in a year but
orientation is what I'm thinking of.
And in the noise of orientation
200 events across six or
seven days, I knew whatever I said
was not going to be memorable.
They were drinking from a firehose, right?
>> Yes.
>> Just trying not to get wet,
just try not to drown and yet
we wanted some of that water to land
because it would be nourishing and so
I aimed to convey that feeling, right?
You will probably not remember the words,
but hopefully,
you are having an experience
of being respected, and
helped ,and aided, and
cared about, and routed for.
So, I think that's the advice,
yes you're going to use words, but
what is it ultimately that
you hope the recipient,
the listener,
the reader is going take away?
My new book Your Turn, the narrative voice
of that took me three years to find and
And it ultimately is trying to be me,
is me trying to be this compassionate,
frank, older person saying, I know
you're terrified, I get that it's valid.
And the thing is,
you gotta step into the adult place.
And I'm here rooting for you and
I'm going to be alongside you on these
pages and you're going to be okay.
Yes, you will.
And to try to do that on the page, I mean,
readers will have to let me
know did I succeed or not?
And maybe in some chapters I did and
others I didn't.
But that's it's trying to imagine
how the other person is going
to receive any of the stuff
you have to offer.
And instead of focusing too much on
who am I, and how am I, what do I,
think about it from their perspective.
It'll take some of the pressure off you,
I think.
And it allows you to create empathy for
your reader, your listener, your audience.
And ultimately, that's going to lead to a
great presentation, a great communication.
>> The notion of focusing
on your audience and
what they need is a recurrent theme that
we hear across these podcast episodes.
What you've added to it around
this notion of really thinking
about the experience and
the feeling is very important as well.
Thank you for all of your time and
your insights, your ideas about support,
compassion, both for ourselves and for the
young adults we're talking to is critical.
And these lessons extend well beyond
transitioning into adulthood.
I encourage everyone to take time to read
Julie's books and to watch her talks.
Thank you so much Julie.
>> Matt, thanks for having me and
to all the listeners thanks for
spending time with me
today I appreciate you.
>> Thank you for
listening to Think Fast Talk Smart,
the podcast, a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
To learn more, go to gsb.stanford.edu.
Please download other episodes
wherever you find your podcasts.
[MUSIC]